well over the weekend and even this
morning we told you about reports of
hikers
ending up stranded and with the warmer
weather search and rescue teams want to
remind hikers of safety measures to
avoid getting lost
bianca holman is live now from lone
mountain with more on that hi bianca
good afternoon alex so spring and summer
busy months for metro search and rescue
teams
matter of fact out here on these trails
a lot more people hitting the trails but
it's important to keep
safety top of mind this morning metro
search for a hiker in the far north part
of the valley
the man called 9-1-1 saying he went for
a hike just north of clark county
shooting complex off decatur
but got lost in the dark metro patrol
cars and a helicopter were used to
locate him
the man was found at dawn and during a
recent news conference at the end of
april metro reported that they
have seen a decrease so far in rescue
since last year
when they rescued 110 hikers
it's down right now probably due to
covid
the parks were closed for a while like
about eight months
the parks were closed completely so
people weren't allowed to go out there
legally some people still went out there
but
we've not seen a large increase
now we're actually seeing a big
reduction from last year so far we're
only at 27
so far this year now here's some advice
to stay safe if you plan to hit the
trails tell someone where you plan to
hike at take someone with you wear
appropriate gear
and bring minimal overnight supplies
just in case again you get stranded
and bring a light source of course and a
charged phone and a couple other things
to bring they recommend
a mini first aid kit and also a bottled
water
reporting live from lone mountain park
bianca holman 8 news now